just engag Tony Ferguson you're excited
about that here's the thing I can't be
more except stylistically it's better
than Conor it's it's Aussie a more a
more entertaining fight than khabib Tony
because Justin will bring the pain he's
not just gonna take him down he'll bring
the pain here's the thing
justin is a beast cuz you just keep
pressing forward and them swings and
takes punished so fun but he will take
the chi all the government all the day
yeah that Cowboys wrong I did because
Justin isn't moving his head he's just
coming in and that's what I'm here for
I know Monday Justin gays he take that
kind of damage I don't like seeing him
know he's number four ranked fighter in
the world so he's [ __ ] good yeah hell
of a restaurant all that does I don't
want to see him get hurt
I don't like secret meet him the odds
are to be that favorable for Tony no
just a great try is a [ __ ] nightmare
however he's the most violent man in the
sport yes there's the most crazy violent
man in the sport yeah Ferguson but but
but this is he Ferguson his core fight
fans not sure dick in the know but he's
going to be met with lots of Tony
Ferguson's fists and that's not he's you
know what it is just engaged she's too
tough for his own good against a guy
like you know who that worries me I mean
you know who John I still I did you know
I now take I like saying I like like
creating I like not saying Tony's name
too often hold on hold on hold on hold
on David just posted this a minutes ago
you stupid [ __ ] get ready their fight is
sign is one hump sent on live on ESPN
somewhere on the earth Tony Ferguson vs.
Justin engag is live on ESPN Plus
pay-per-view the whole terrible idea a
bright teen for the interim lightweight
belt okay here's the problem there's a
few problems with this my idea why
support this is because they shouldn't
be a pay-per-view the economy doesn't
have money
and we just want free content
everybody's good not very so you want
the most eyeballs possible
you haven't promoted this thing you've
given it a week people are upset you're
doing the event stream it live so it's
the most viewed fight of all time great
and market that a wire if you're asking
$69.99 that's insane it's too much
because people and you can't hold it in
any bar or anything because nobody's
gonna go so you know what that's very
very that's very surprising but doing a
paper they won't tell the location so
they don't want people protesting I
think that's I you know I said this on
my show I a part of me is proud of you
for doing this because I think if you're
Dana White let's say you're Dana White
right you're let's say you're here
definitely leaves which is going let's
say it's gone for good right
and you're Dana White and your auntie
Artie hey you have four hundred dollars
in the bank okay and you control all the
careers of these fantastic fighters and
I give you the stats that I gave you
this morning of ninety seven percent of
people who do get our fine the the the
percentage how how deadly it really
isn't and and then I tell you most of my
contagion level by the correct that's
what I'm saying and and the fighters on
the card or a and the best shapes of any
athletes on the planet they're all under
let's say thirty five so you have a 90%
chance of this thing going smooth as
[ __ ] yeah ninety eight percent would you
would you put the fight on 100 percent
right so so can I just say to everybody
measles has a contagion level of between
12 and 18 what that means that between
12 and 18 people can catch it if you're
around them highly contagious smallpox
killed so many people through the
twentieth century and before a contagion
level three point five to six measles
renders you sterile if you're a boy
usually and led to pneumonia and all
kinds of terrible thing horrible blows
smallpox is was deadly in many cases and
left scarring and everything else
horrible way to die common cold has a
contagion level of between two and three
mm-hm
seasonal strains of influenza reported
to have a contagion level of 0.9 to 2.1
now that's the flu the early data ANCOVA
19 estimates are between 1.4 and 3.9 I'm
not saying I am really not saying that
we want to put anybody's life at risk
who has an underlying health issues the
elderly of obviously preacher I am
saying we need some perspective and I am
saying that there has to be with
treatment and things there has to be a
smarter way to do this a blanket
shutdown a
you seen what Sweden's doing no but I
know they're not doing a shutdown
they're going you guys are adults yes
things contagious yes we're masks
controlled environment and you look at
their stats and it's really not much
different than right and I think
entrepreneurs and businesses for example
let's just take a small restaurant we
know that we have I was just in target
yesterday a lot of people there but they
let you in periodically and there are a
lot of businesses that are open a lot of
businesses and they do it in a smart way
Supermarket lazy people are under
Walmart good have small restaurants oh
yeah open and you could do the same
thing you really could well they are
open they're only for takeout right yeah
but that's not helping them though
that's killing those restaurants because
you need waiters what still no waiters
yes yeah no tip and and I just I do
think there's a smarter way to do this
and I do think also that businesses a
lot of times are pretty good at figuring
out ways to keep their staff healthy
themselves healthy and and their clients
healthy so I I just get really really I
get concerned and I get nervous when a
politician a mayor or governor just does
a blanket thing to cover his ass I get
it
I understand California mayors being
pretty [ __ ] about it he's using I think
we're done for 2020 yeah and that
[ __ ] bothers me because it's it's
just a [ __ ] number of irresponsible
it really is it seems like I'm putting
fear and everybody yeah I know there are
people listening right now who are like
you have no idea no I do have an idea
you have no idea yeah neither do a lot
of you with the antibodies let's let's
fight us so what's up bro
I know stats and it's pretty black and
white yeah and if I'm Dana why I'm the
UFC I'm definitely throwing this event
and here's the thing there's a 98%
chance everything to be just fine a
hundred percent and and now and I when I
when I say I prove and I'm proud to UFC
I'm assuming they've taken all the
necessary measures to make sure all the
fighters are clear they've done the
testing there's you mean no one in the
audience I don't see I and listen if
you're surprised that the UFC is doing
this you don't know the UFC they're
gunslingers they made to the top by
taking risk
yeah and they've taken bigger risks that
much of a risk no that's what I'm saying
much of the numbers and these numbers
this isn't something I made
these are these are the same numbers
that any news outlet you're watching
they're spinning super- they're using
these numbers yeah in my guys my my my
concern comes from when you shut down an
entire economy my concern comes with
unemployment and all the all the the
recession causing measures that were
doing that could get so bad man that
that's what I worry about daddy has a
date end of June yeah I spoke in
Washington and I think that's gonna
happen
that's very optimistic and I like your
optimism I like your optimism and I
think the USCS can be the guinea pig and
other leagues and go oh they were fine
and they're [ __ ] swapping body fluids
and they're good all right NFL let's get
rolling college football let's get
rolling MBA let's get rolling yeah
well these are young people strong young
people yeah again look at that without
the child what risk getting taken yeah
did your player fighters has more risk
of dying in the car and on the way to
the arena I [ __ ] dying from Kobe 19
so how far do we want to go with this
dad I'm gonna fight you I love to fight
you I would love to fight you do I'd
like to punch you in students let's do a
pay-per-view 1999 people pay right now
and I will [ __ ] you up okay punch you in
the 1999 I will give buying Corona
weight you want to fight and what are
you what are the rules you want to do
MMA what do you want to do you [ __ ]
Street rules
Street rules take your steel [ __ ] he
jabs all jokes aside you [ __ ] you
giant [ __ ] don't say boo better than
that you're more creative [ __ ] Mon
dude I know I don't might be mean I
can't say anything even when I want to
be I can't think of any yeah you [ __ ]
[ __ ] couch dude I can't wait for you
see 249 didn't you say yeah I heard
Francis and Rosen's shoe Crusoe's behind
it too but there's someone else a couple
other people that really excited me uh
that would be hospital is he fighting no
you're so frustrating Rose namajunas and
Jessica and Roger supposed to fight out
it'll be fun Rose namajunas she was
announcing the whole card
that's insane they're trying to a
pay-per-view though that's it's so
stupid why are they doing that because
they need money yeah but no they're not
gonna get it and money no they County
[ __ ]
well no other details yet it's weird
there's no other details let's check out
do Justin Gacy tony is [ __ ] pure fire
I like how people are given to be [ __ ]
for not be able to make the fight you
know stupid you'd have to be company of
his back in Russia he's like I'm not
taking this fight we lad came to go to
the gym the gyms closed I can't you know
what do you want me to I don't have
training partners the it's on it's off
you think I'm not taking this the Corona
boys can't wait to see you see 249
Corona boys that's what they should do
we'll see that Ferguson can be provided
soon as this thing is lifted I think I
think Tony beets ehe yeah and then you
get a Tony could be but just build it
even more in August if you had to bet
$100,000 on khabib and I know you had a
point of view could be Ferguson can't
bet on it but I would like I wanna bet
alone I wouldn't bet on them there's too
many variables it's such a good fight
yeah you'd ruin it if I bet on it yeah I
just want to enjoy it to see what the
game plan is what a move by the UFC
though what a move I wonder what the
other car the rest of the cards even
look like say who do warrants Cody car
brand about potential flyweight move can
Cody get down to 25 yeah it's weird they
don't have any of the car and then they
want to sell it because they were doing
all the right feet oh I thought was
gonna show the card mama they might have
the old no no Justin they took all of
mine this morning it was the entire card
so they're gonna do I can't believe
they're charging for that people are
gonna legally stream the [ __ ] out of
that yeah including me
why wait you pregnant usually have the
links you and just like shut them down
what you and Justin Gates you have
someone noses
he went bad he got you guys when you did
food diaries he kind of gave you some
business on how you were talking about
him what was he doesn't like that I say
he's reckless
he says it's controlled and smart
recklessness I begged the different we
got into it it was a fun discussion I've
known Justin gay G for what you are we
I've known him since 2013
you had long longer did you know when I
start fighting in what doing nine so I
met him 2010 did you train with him yep
a ton he came with no experience his
coach was my head coach at Easter
bowling he was an all-american wrestler
from UNC so we had to go up there to
wrestle so I'm not Justin for a very
long time Wow
Justin's always been a monster it is
stupid athletic really Oh backflips and
just head but it had no um kicks like a
mule but didn't know how to punch him
kick when he got nobody wanted to he
always wanted to fight stud super stud
just dad doesn't want a wrestle just
wants to [ __ ] yeah a really good athlete
but no athlete and and and wants and
mentally strong you the Hindman no one's
gonna quit in that fight it's such a
great fun yeah Wow you have to kill
Justin oh I've known Justin before he's
fighting uh-huh Wow stud super stud
that's that's why he's able to talk to
me like that
when you when you're a heavyweight in
training like that you don't train with
the lighter guys dude yeah we do you do
yo some yeah but not really I mean
you're doing you're rolling in stuff
you're you're not sparring it's not
spine now put the wrestling rolling we
will yeah have you eights it's tough to
get big bodies man that's a pain in the
ass yeah Jesus stud that's such a good
fight I'm so happy
if something look forward to yep well
should be interesting I would assume
Tony's a slight favorite uh-huh
dude they have to rest the card on it
this is just the betting on side so this
is just if everyone does get on the card
fights Jesus Christ Rothwell really
auntie Jesus Christ feeling out there
stuff like Stephens Calvin Calvin cater
it's amazing fight Mecca Jeff phenomenal
fight Rose just gone Josh Jesus that's
the card but there's rumors that it was
Rosen struck in Francis right yeah
because the rumors were it's supposed to
be like a like an insane card which this
is insane but I just thought it's gonna
be like an old-school UFC 100 or some
[ __ ] it's crazy I'll tight-lip they've
been I reached out to all my I'm talking
about the the people who run with Dana
White and they won't
everyone's tight nothing they may not
know and they don't know that that's the
thing they don't know do i dude I'm
telling you we've tried nothing up in
the air man well he doesn't want it to
get out and the people protest and make
a big deal about it one but we see
Connor fight again
I wonder summer after I would imagine
Connors waiting the links for the khabib
21st and result yeah but he'll fight
before then hopefully like Dustin
Poirier or something like that
really oh yeah then I can you Mattel
shut yeah he could if he wanted he could
wait for keep on Tony yeah be a long
wait you went fight he'd fight what he
wants to fight three times this year if
he waits for that he won't fight till
October yeah that's not good no do you
have idea for him I'm tell you this
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]